y en directo a nos vamos hasta este
viernes hasta México ayer presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador aseguró
tener pruebas del tráfico ilegal de
fentanilo desde china hacia su país
luego de detectar un contenedor con esta
sustancia en un barco llegado desde el
puerto chino de quintao al puerto del
Lázaro Cárdenas en Michoacán amlo ya
envió una misiva a Beijing para pedir
ayuda a la capital china a la hora de
combatir el tráfico de esta droga desde
sus puertos china ha negado que esto
suceda y amlo afirmó que enviará una
nueva carta a su homólogo chino para
reiterar el pedido para ahondar en este
tema hablamos con nuestro corresponsal
Mario carbonell Mario Cómo lograron las
autoridades mexicanas detectar el
fentanilo en el cargamento
Hola Así es bueno fue el secretario de
Marina quien refirió Cómo fue que
hallaron este cargamento dijo que de
entrada los perros adiestrados
detectaron algo raro en ese en ese
cargamento en Lázaro Cárdenas y
procedieron a su inspección dijo que
eran 600 bultos de una sustancia
denominada resina de combustible cada
adulto tenía alrededor de 34 35 kilos y
lo que hicieron fue coordinar tres
distintos laboratorios el laboratorio de
la Secretaría de Marina especializado en
detección de drogas sintéticas el
laboratorio de la aduana de Lázaro
Cárdenas y también el de la Comisión
Federal para protección contra riesgos
sanitarios y determinaron que ese
cargamento venía contaminado con
fentanilo es así que pues le hicieron
una segunda revisión y confirmaron en
efecto esta sustancia Por lo cual se
informó al Gobierno Federal y eso dio
que el presidente como ya lo mencionabas
dijera que se tienen finalmente las
pruebas de lo que china había negado
china había sido enfático en que no
había ninguna ningún registro de envíos
ni de tráfico ni legal ni ilegal hacia
México de fentanilo Por lo cual Se
enviará esta misiva y Mario Más allá de
las misivas de las que hemos hablado
cuál está siendo la postura de amlo
sobre esta droga que se está produciendo
en masa en México
Sí el presidente
ha sostenido que en México no se produce
fentanilo que una y otra vez ha dicho
que aquí no se produce esta sustancia
sino que la mano de obra llega la
materia prima perdón llega desde china
esto a pesar de que se ha publicado que
desde 2018 la propia las propias fuerzas
armadas han detectado una decena de
Laboratorios de drogas sintéticas entre
ellas el fentanilo el presidente ha
dicho que aquí Únicamente se troquelan
las pastillas que no no se produce aquí
como tal la sustancia
dice que ha sido un argumento que
utilizan los candidatos en Estados
Unidos que aspiran algún cargo de
elección popular y que utilizan este
tema de manera electoral de cualquier
forma el presidente ha instruido a que
se haga una campaña en las escuelas para
prevenir a los jóvenes a los estudiantes
de los riesgos que conlleva el consumo
de esta sustancia